[Music]
so recap on what we learned last week
yes so every Metal Gear game has you
playing as one snake or another and you
have to infiltrate military bases under
the pretense of gathering Intel or
rescuing someone but pretty much every
time you get there you come face to face
with a giant nuclear weapons launcher
called a Metal Gear which you have to
take down and then inevitably you are
double triple or even quadruple crossed
that has been known to happen
so last week's episode was everything
pre phantom pain this is post phantom
pain which means were all about the
clones
more specifically big bosses clones
solid liquid and solid us because
apparently gas snake was too much even
Fatima that makes me Serb with her
therapy no starting is run as a rookie
Foxhound special ops agent Solid Snake
gets sent into military base outer Haven
by big boss remember him he aims to
rescue fellow agent gray fox an
investigative potential Metal Gear but
he's been set up big bosses revealed his
outer havens leader who wants to use the
metal gear to make outer Haven a place
soldiers can live free from government
ideology and nuclear power after a
scrapped solid confronts and defeats his
father Big Boss but he doesn't know that
he's his dad yet after being called out
of retirement for the first time solid
is sent to Zanzibar lands that last
nuclear power to grab a recipe for
synthetic oil which the world
desperately needs after grabbing the
data defeating gray fox and a Metal Gear
Solid learns that Big Boss also run
Zanzibar land and so they fight again
and Big Boss loses again called out of
retirement again Solid Snake is set
against his clone brother liquid snake
who's taking control of Fox Sound and a
bunch of nuclear weapons on Shadow Moses
Island liquids plan is to release nukes
on the United States unless they
relinquish the body of Big Boss so they
can make a powerful army of clones saleh
takes on liquid and Foxhound but lee's
revolver ocelot
you know that guy that double-crosses
everybody snake is now a freedom fighter
destroying rogue metal gears built after
the shadow moses incident he's called to
take a look at a tanker containing a new
Metal Gear
Ocelot shows up kills a bunch of people
and blames it on snake a while later a
facility is set up to cover up the
oil spill caused by snake a new snake
Affairs called Dryden who has to follow
the floss of Metal Gear Solid 1 but on
an oil platform he even gets to fight a
cyborg ninja and a clone of snake this
time solidus he has extra arms and
swords and stuff there's also a small
matter of world domination intent a eyes
created by them Patriots poor Solid
Snake is prematurely aging due to being
a clone Annie's on the hunt to kill
liquid Ocelot who is just regular Ocelot
but with liquids arm that has somehow
hypnotized him Ocelot intends to hijack
the networked AI soldiers that the
Patriots have created so let's think
it's yanked out of retirement again and
takes out liquid Ocelot and the Patriots
artificial intelligence which was trying
to control the world and now he just
wants to live out his days in peace
and that's Metal Gear Solid plain and
simple I'm back how was it well it turns
out my mushy head thinker has what they
call an absurdity limit and seeing
animal hats in games pushes me into the
red line so what does that mean it means
that if I see an animal hat really in
any scenario my head will melt sound bad
I missed you guys too muddy
[Music]
I'm back Oh God